In today's video,
we're going to try making
root beer using dry ice
inside a pressurized container.
[Music]
Guys, I'm Nate.
I'm Calli.
I'm The Hacksmith.
We've got the Hacksmith joining
us for an experiment today,
and I think it's gonna
be pretty fun.
So Calli, what are we
going to be doing here?
We want to make root beer,
but we want to make
a lot of it.
We want to try and carbonate
it with the dry ice,
but we need a bigger
container to do that.
Well, why don't you guys use
the old flame thrower?
That is an excellent idea.
Our flamethrower,
if you haven't seen
the build video,
is actually made
out of a CO2 tank.
This is designed for holding
carbon dioxide,and so
while it's usually
a bad idea to put dry ice
in sealed containers,
this one can handle it.
The idea here is simple.
We're going to mix up a batch
of root beer flavoring and sugar
inside our flamethrower tank.
We'll then add a lot
of dry ice, seal it up,
and hopefully, it will both
pressurize the tank,
and carbonate the root beer.
All right.
So before we start
mixing up some root beer,
why don't we do
a quick test using water?
Just to see how it's
actually going to react.
This whole tank holds
about three and a half
gallons of liquid.
I think we're going to start off
with about two just to give
some space in there.
And I smash it with a hammer.
[Music]
We've got water in the tank,
and as soon as the dry ice
hits that water,
it is going to start
building pressure.
So there's a good chance
that some of our dry
ice is kind of,
can start getting
like spit back out.
So I'm going to try
and do it little bits
at a time to minimize that.
We'll see how this goes.
[Music]
Okay, we actually got
quite a bit in there.
Let's go for one more, then
we're going to throw this in.
We're going to put this on
with the valve open.
So all of the escaping
pressure can come out,
because otherwise,
it builds up pressure so far
that you can't thread
it on all the way.
All right.
Let's try this.
[Music]
It's on.
Close it off,
and now hopefully,
it's building up pressure
inside the tank.
Oh boy, that's...
[Music]
This is not supposed to happen.
What do you think?
Should we risk it?
Just try it with the--
We might as well.
Try with the root beer.
Let's do it.
All right.
So to make the root beer,
we're going to start
mixing ingredients together,
including two and
a half cups of sugar.
There is a lot of sugar in soda.
[Music]
All right, so now we're going
to use some root beer extract,
and we need 2 tablespoons
to 1 gallon.
Oh, like a pro.
Look at that, not a drop wasted.
[Music]
That's really strong too.
I might have spilled
too much into mine.
Just how much of a mess
is this about to make as
soon as we start pouring
the dry ice into it?
You, ready?
So far so good.
You're right.
I think we should give it
just a minute to really
build up some pressure
and carbonate that root beer.
All right, I think
we need to do a test.
See how well
this thing is shooting.
All right, here we go.
3, 2, 1.
Awesome!
Not bad.
Wait!
Don't aim at me.
Aim where you're aiming before,
I'm gonna catch it.
All right.
[Music]
No!
Yep, that's aluminum root beer.
[Music]
Root beer foam.
That's not bad.
I would say it's
slightly less carbonated
than most root beer are going
to get in the bottle,
but it definitely is fizzy.
Definitely is foamy.
Man, it's root beer.
Not bad.
It does have a slight taste
of the aluminum container
that it's been sitting in.
Bartender, fill me up.
Thank you, Bartender.
Hey, thank you ,Bartender.
[Music]
All right. I'm going to shoot
this straight up, and see
if I can at least get
some into this cup.
[Music]
Some!
I've got a precision
challenge for you.
Rather than a mug,
I just have a soda bottle.
We're going to see
if you can fill the soda bottle
from like 8 feet away.
You're good.
So when are we gonna put
those ponchos on?
Oh yeah, about that,
about that poncho.
Oh, that glove is now...
Look at this,
Make a fist and squeeze,
root beer just drips
out of my glove.
It is completely soaked.
Now, we got a bottle
with some root beer,
and a lot of root
beer foam in it.
I don't think you're going
to get the whole word.
[Music]
You can totally do it.
We did it!
Hacksmith.
We've, we've got all the
ingredients and supplies to do
that a couple more times.
Let's make some more.
>> Yeah.
>> All right.
[Music]
Oh boy.
The bottom of
our tank is frozen.
Oh, no.
I wonder if that means
the hose is frozen.
Only one way to find out.
Now, when Grant
invited me down here,
I had no idea I get to shoot
both Nate and Calli,
so I'm pretty excited.
Let see how it goes.
[Music]
Oh, it torn through.
Now, you can protect yourself.
3, 2.
[Music]
This is actually
frozen to the board.
This is--
It's a slush.
He's shooting me with slush.
All right, I say
let's do another batch
that had a lot more power.
Yeah.
But it gave us a lot of issues.
Yeah, the freezing bottom.
And we didn't get
a nice stream of root beer,
we got like a hard spray.
We had the same problem
with this thing
when we would use the CO2
in the normal fuel
as a flamethrower,
is that with too much pressure,
it tends to just vaporize a
little bit on contact with air.
So I think we should go back
to the other method,
root beer first,
then the dry ice.
Maybe we can have
a shooting competition to see
who can fill a mug fastest.
It's time for a little
friendly competition.
We've got three mugs over there,
and we're gonna see
who can fill the mug
the most in 10 seconds.
So we'll each take
10 seconds, and see
who can fill their mug most.
3, 2, 1
. 1.
10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
He actually got some in there.
I definitely went
to 11 seconds too.
3, 2, 1.
. 10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Got extra second.
I don't think I got any, guys.
It's all right.
>> I think..
>> Little bit.
Not much, but I think some.
To be fair, it's first time I
have ever shot that so...
All right. Now we've got the expert,
who's already been doing this.
No pressure.
Alright 3, 2, 1.
10, 9, 8, 7, 6,
5, 4, 3, 2...
I think he gets a few
more extra second now.
Aw, that's too bad.
Oh, well, we beat him.
Let's check this out.
Let's see how we do.
Guys, we're all terrible.
That looks pretty empty to me.
There's a drip.
I got maybe a tablespoon.
Yeah.
Yeah, we got,
we got two drips each.
And that, Nate's
the clear winner.
Almost a quarter of a swallow.
Thanks to James
for being this channel.
James, tell us a little bit
about The Hacksmith.
What do you guys do?
Our series is called
Make It Real,
where we take fictional ideas
from comics, movies,
and video games,
and we try and make real
working versions in real life.
There's a good chance
if you guys are a fan
of our type of videos,
you've already seen
some of his videos,
and if not,
you absolutely should go check
them out as soon as possible.
It's amazing.
Guys, that's it for today.
But you know,
the fun doesn't end here.
We've always got more
for you to see.
That box up at the top will take
you directly to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box will show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next,
and if you hit
this bomb the middle,
you'll be subscribe
to the channel.
That way you'll never miss
out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.